I knew I should
have had butterflies
about Harry Hamilton.
That’s what’s normal.
But, I never did.
I had those feelings—
I have those feelings...
about girls.
And, I tried to
be like you...
but I’m just not.
Mother walked in on me...
in New York,
with a maid.
She looked at me
like I was a monster.
Mabel, I’m so sorry.
What did she say?
She just...
walked back out,
like I was nothing.
Mabel, listen to me.
Listen.
You’re talking about...
love.
How can love
ever be wrong?
If that’s what gives
you butterflies,
then you are exactly who
you’re supposed to be.
You’re Mabel.
You’re beautiful.
You’re not disgusted?
Darling...
Shame?
You have to try
and let that go.
You’re too lovely
to be ruined.
Thank you for telling me.